that's all I can know if you talk about
you Loveridge well I love Ridge Walla -
look I'm tired of carrying a wallet in
my back pocket because for me it just
feels a little archaic and uncomfortable
like people looking them out back of my
pants and been like oh is that guy a
camel you know look at the love of his
pants so now you get to work with that
new front pocket carry dude that's real
this is crazy that we're adults and this
is that here your butt will open up a
little I know you don't know that's I
like sometimes my Turkish kiss they call
throw a skittle in there duck you know
yeah so I can survive man but anyway you
know I don't like when people accused me
of uh being weak my bad man and I think
you could survive out there look I think
you're the kind of person that they
would find in a you know in a cave or
something they would find you you know
some a couple of um
soccer players with no soccer balls a
couple of Cub Scout to get lost in the
woods right right somewhere in Polynesia
or Eurasia yeah and they get lost in the
woods and or maybe they're like young
and they're like you know thinking about
acting out sexually and they're both
kind of experimenting right and they
slip off in the woods together two boys
and they're taking it off each other
scarves and just [ __ ] just being wild
and just you know feeling pressing each
other's just medium hard [ __ ] up
against each other's merit badges and
just learning about each other you know
right just learning about each other
just [ __ ] rubbing sticks together out
there
yeah and then one of them falls through
like a hole in the ground or something
like a magical hole or not even a
magical hole just like a weak part of
dirt and and then all of a sudden they
fall in like a place in you're there
right and you're sitting on a chair like
he's dead this guy's been dead yeah yeah
yeah and uh but do I have words of
wisdom when you open your eyes I open my
eyes I say something [ __ ] this guy isn't
dead
yeah and dead right and then you say
something right I say Tommy's about to
say something yeah he's about to say
something clean air air twice believe
increments grams molecules believe bend
over that's what I'd say oh yeah yeah
and then you'd be confused right then I
if I have a snake date
oh my dick shaped like a snake okay they
hear it first though like that it's got
a rattle snake no no it's my dick whoa
right molecules keeps laying their
leaders yeah and curlies bend over
just do it LeBrons and then and then I
just turn into ash yes oh no gone and
let me tell you this right now right
they will never forget it
I'll leave that Yeah right I was
watching a Star Trek enter and they get
married one day - and they have a son
named Bobby Lee yeah
[Music]